good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday I don't know if this is true for
you but for me at any one time I'm able
to follow about six news stories so
right now I've got the economic crisis
I've got Iraq
I've got Pakistan then I've got the
Craigslist killer and then fifth I have
a pretty good handle on North Korea and
then lastly of course I've been closely
following the breakup of Lindsay Lohan
and Samantha I don't know your last name
and wish I didn't know your first name
so admittedly Hank six news stories
isn't a lot but I feel like a pretty
well-informed citizen but then along
comes a news story like Sri Lanka and
I'm like oh there's been a civil war
going on
Oh for 30 years now Hank I'm not here to
yell at people about not paying
attention to the extremely serious
situation in Sri Lanka because it's not
your fault for not paying attention to
it because it's complicated and no one
has ever explained it to you while
rubbing creamy peanut butter on his face
yes Hank I know how to get people to pay
attention to serious international news
stories peanut butter face okay Hank so
pop quiz what religion are the people
who invented both contemporary suicide
bombings and the suicide vest that's
right Hank they're Hindus also some are
Christian um and they're not terribly
religious I'm referring of course to the
Tamil Tigers the separatist group
currently in sri lanka getting the crap
bombed out of them by the Sri Lankan
government I don't know why I'm applying
the peanut butter only to the places
where I would shave so I have to
understand the Tamil Tigers we actually
have to go back to 1956 Sri Lanka had
just gained its independence a few years
before and the majority Buddhist Sinha
Lee's ethnic group decided that
Sinhalese should be the only language in
all of Sri Lanka and that Buddhism
should be the official religion well
heck I'm sure I don't need to tell you
how the Tamil minority felt about that
happening they didn't like it so these
tensions simmer for decades and finally
in 1983 war breaks out a group called
the Tamil Tigers is fighting for an
independent Tamil State in the north and
east of Sri Lanka while the Sri Lankan
government is fighting to keep the
island a single country and it's a
difficult thing hang because you can't
have every single ethnic group that
wants its own country having its own
country on the other hand the
government has never treated the tamil
people equally or fairly in Sri Lanka
over the years the Wars killed more than
80,000 people and there are really no
good guys in this war the Sri Lankan
government is in arguably to blame for
the disappearance of many Tamils and the
table Tigers aside from being a
terrorist organization according to a
long list of countries are also famous
not only for their suicide bombings but
also for their recruitment of child
soldiers in 2002 after almost 20 years
of this on-again off-again civil war the
Sri Lankan government and the Tamil
Tigers finally signed a ceasefire and
everyone was so relieved and so excited
and there was some thought that
eventually like the Tamil majority part
of Sri Lanka might have some measure of
autonomy but then in the beginning of
this year the war erupted again and now
the Tamil Tigers are on the run and they
control very little territory and the
Sri Lankan government has them
surrounded and is basically just trying
to pound them into submission but as is
the nature of rebel groups particularly
like ones that are suicidally bent on
independence there's not really any
winning but hey the worst part of the
story is that in the last three months
the UN estimates that more than 6,000
civilians have been killed either by the
government or by the Tamil Tigers and
Hank when there are no obvious
candidates for the evil baby orphanage
it's really easy for the international
community just to get bored and stop
watching we like to follow news stories
that make sense and when news stories
ask us to think hard and make difficult
judgments about ambiguous situations we
tend to you know only pay attention to
them when someone is slathered in peanut
butter which by the way if you are
wondering is really uncomfortable my
face wants to sweat but it can't so Hank
that's my peanut butter face
introduction to the civil war currently
raging in Sri Lanka let's hope for an
immediate ceasefire so we can have these
insanely complicated political
discussions without killing thousands of
people
just a few seconds just all Hank when
Willie sleeps he dreams of a world in
which all people have peanut butter face